Steven Crowder has somehow got this
Manifesto and he released it so here is
a tweet from Crowder and we'll see if we
make it through YouTube today uh
breaking Nashville School Covenant
shooter Audrey hail's death day
Manifesto targeted crackers with white
privileges want to kill all you little
crackers these are quotes obviously from
the manifesto I hope I have a high death
count I'm ready I hope my victims aren't
ready to die uh Elon Musk responded to
this and he wrote this uh clearly
mentally ill but also clearly
brainwashed into being a mass murderer
by the system now I think it's worth uh
discussing that point for a second
because anyone who commits any of these
murders is mentally ill by definition
you guys remember that Uvalde shooting
in Texas the school where I think 18
kids and three teachers were shot Cold
Blood murder absolutely horrible that
was about six or eight months ago and we
played that clip of Joy Reed the next
day on her show saying that the shooter
was not mentally ill this was about the
guns and that is what a mentally ill
person would say the very definition of
taking a gun and shooting innocent
people children who you don't know all
of that that is by definition you are
mentally ill but that doesn't suit Joy
Reed and MSNBC and the Democrat party's
policy of wanting to step on your second
amendment rights right your ability to
own a firearm and protect yourself so
they don't want you to think about
mental health they don't want you to
think about the mindbending prescription
drugs that people are on or on this case
the fact that the shooter was trans and
there's probably hormones involved and
everything
else